Moving down the list of LinkedIn
sections, let's get started
with how to create an interesting and
memorable summary section.
The summary section is typically
one to four sentences.
And it functions somewhat like a short
elevator pitch where you get to
convey the most important information of
what you're all about professionally.
Remember the results
of your Rs activity.
Write for your intended recruiters and
employers.
Use clear, action-oriented language.
Integrate key words
generated in your three Rs.
Highlight your strengths, skills,
past accomplishments, and
current projects that are especially
relevant to the field or
position that you'd like
to transition into.
Finally, treat your profile
like a cover letter and
frame your professional interest as
passions that you want to pursue.
If you love doing something, don't wash
it down and say you like or enjoy it.
A quick example is that I love
learning from my teammates at work.
Rather than stating I enjoy
collaborative environments,
my summary statement says passionate
about collaboration and peer coaching.